so yeah you're asking such a great
question I think that there's a huge
role in other faith communities in the
concept of Education one of the things
that I talk about when I go overseas I
get a lot of questions from people who
say why did why do they think they
meaning non-muslims think this of us
don't they know the Quran don't they
know whatever and my first question is
what do you know about the Bible what do
you know about the Torah how do you talk
about Jews how do you talk about Muslims
are you bi mean Christians are you being
respectful as you it's a mutual
education process for everybody my mom
is a retired doctor and practiced in
Massachusetts for almost 30 years and
retired and went to Atlanta
don't ask me so she gets down there and
I called her one night and she didn't
answer the phone and I thought it was
really weird because she's supposed to
be home and when she finally got hold
her I'm like well where were you and she
said I was at Bible study and I said
what and she said I was at Bible study
and I said mom tell me you're not
converting because it would be really
bad for my career you know like really
bad um no but she but she said Farah
look you know I had a group of neighbors
there and they were doing Bible study
and they said to her you know we're
going we're leaving now we're going to
go to Bible study and she said well can
I come and she said I know the Bible
really well and I would really enjoy
having a conversation well she's been
doing this for two years now she and her
friends who are Christians have done
this interfaith thing in a very small
way it's grown to a bigger thing that's
one micro that's a little piece of sand
right on a beach but this is happening
all over the world these kinds of
opportunities to learn from each other
means she talked to them she she broke
down stereotypes of what it means to be
with some woman right then and there
because like you said there's a lot of
misunderstanding but there's
misunderstanding not just for from
Christians or Jews or Hindus they're
also misunderstandings from any Muslims
and what it means what others I mean so
that the more my feeling is the more
that we can do to open up opportunities
for conversation the critical side will
tell you you're talking to your own
you're talking to people who are open to
that kind of thing shouldn't we be
talking to people who my whole feeling
is
the wave needs to start and we need to
keep going going forward there's no
downside to educating yourself about
about about others a lot of Muslims too
I will say to you are really ignorant
about Islam in other parts of the world
so they see themselves and in their own
framework and they're involved in their
own little life and they don't know
for example Muslim women I think it's
really interesting if anybody wants to
do a PhD on the growing trend of of how
Muslim female imaging I would love to
have a conversation with you because
there's some really interesting things
that are happening on why Muslim women
in 2010 are covering when their
grandmothers and their mothers never did
it's really phenomenally interesting and
a lot of data points there but what I
was going to say is a lot of these young
people who are Muslim don't know the
conversations that are happening between
culture and religion and other parts of
the world and so they are very isolated
and they have no resources to actually
talk to each other this is where
technology comes in as well when you
open up that space so that people are
talking about key issues you're talking
about you know the person in Mali and
the person in Tajikistan are having a
conversation about something that in
fact is very central to to them at this
moment in time and it's in real time
it's really important so more the more
conversation you have the more education
you have and the more we can actually
access other faith groups to have
conversations with a dignified stance I
think the better we will all be yeah